i haven't seen you since
uh obviously the shooting man and you
know you're walking around without
crutches uh
how are you feeling i'm feeling good i'm
feeling good just
getting my [ __ ] back getting the
strength back of my [ __ ] like in my calf
and my foot and everything
i'm seeing an injury like that take time
you know i'm saying the heel back from
but i'm good
when that happened it was was it was it
a parking lot at walmart or something or
was it yeah
in texas was it houston or dallas it was
houston yeah like
what was this like what like like i feel
like we always talk about obviously
everything i don't know man
you know i mean it was it was it was a
crazy it was some crazy [ __ ] but
some [ __ ] got up on me you know i'm
saying you know just regular [ __ ]
is it hard cause you you you move around
a lot um
is it like something like that does it
kind of
does it make you hesitant to be outside
as much
because i feel like you know you could
you could even get some like
you know p psd from some [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah that's a fact
uh and yeah a little bit but what i'm
gonna say is not
as much as not more than anything else
that i've been through right you've been
through something
you've seen me like okay i need to sit
my ass down right now
[ __ ] like that for so it's just more
[ __ ] like that you see you see how i'm
moving around right now i ain't gonna
let that [ __ ] take over my life and
i'm gonna move smart though you know i
mean yeah cause i had that conversation
with conway because he you know he told
me
how i think it was in atlanta some
somewhere where you guys were out on the
road and
and he got caught slipping and he was
like yo man that [ __ ] happened and it
kind of made me re-kind of evaluate
you know we you know i'm around rap
[ __ ] is targets we targets you know
what i'm saying
especially during a pandemic hungry
i don't even think it's no pandemic [ __ ]
i think it's a clout thing you know what
i'm saying
i think it's a cloud thing you know
cause [ __ ]
it's a rapper thing you know what i mean
it ain't no like a athlete thing and
they know you know
athletes get god and [ __ ] like that you
know [ __ ] love to press up on rappers
used to be the same [ __ ] who'll be in
our face though
well we also hear about it when it
happens to a rapper i don't think we
ever hear about it that's what
that's that's what i'm saying like it
happens
yeah i mean and then also too like it's
got to make you very very careful about
like
posting where you're at oh yeah i wasn't
doing no [ __ ] like that anyway
you know some people are reckless bro
you know what cause they don't you know
they was probably thinking like me in a
sense you know what i'm saying
uh you don't you know you know you you
you taking you're taking certain
precautions but
you got to take every precaution you
know what i mean that type of [ __ ]
that's some real [ __ ] man